mais bien que nous avons débuté à
l'heure la commission des lois ce matin
les collègues ont été passionné par les
textes du coup ça a pris un peu de temps
et on est un peu on est un peu en retard
donc je vous présente mes excuses en
tous les cas je vous demande de
m'accorder les vôtres merci de votre
présence physique bien évidemment ah et
qui est-ce que j'ai vu c'est Monsieur
dub que j'aperçois c'est ça voilà très
bien merci de de de votre présence ce
matin je suis accompagné de plusieurs
collègues peut-être que vous ne les
voyez pas mais madameage brigot madame
Nar et Monsieur Vogel qui sont des
commissaires au loi des membres de la
commission des lois et qui suivent bien
sûr la mission d'information qui sont
mis en sur les émeutes qui sont survenus
le 24 juin dernier enfin du 24 juin au
début du mois de juillet mais bien que
nousons débuté à l'heure la commission
des lois ce matin les collègues ont été
passionnés par les
textes c'est moi qui dit ça ça devient
dramatique et donc dans le travail que
nous menons dont l'objectif est d'avoir
un rapport mois de février ça c'est une
chose c'est essayer de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et à travers j'allais dire
tous les sujets c'est-à-dire que bien
évidemment que la commission des lois
s'intéresse aux problèmes juridiques
premier sécurité très bien mais pas
seulement on veut essayer de d'avoir une
approche multifactorielle et en tous les
cas une connaissance assez précise de ce
qui s'est passer pour potentiellement
proposer une évolution législative je
dis bien potentiellement ou un certain
nombre de recommandations qui pe être de
nature réglementaire c'est-à-dire qui
dépend du gouvernement mais en tous les
cas ne pas passer à travers ou ne pas
éviter quelconque euh sujet voilà donc
je vais vous laisser la parole très
rapidement maintenant je sais pas si
vous avez prévu un ordre entre vous ou
pas du tout auquel cas euh je vais
peut-être donner la parole à Monsieur
jardin vous êtes d'accord entendu bon
ben voilà entendu merci beaucoup
[Musique]
HH alors en mon travail c'est d'être
ingénieur de recherche au CNRS donc je
travaille beaucoup sur de l'analyse de
données euh et ça fait maintenant une
15aine d'années que je travaille sur la
question des quartiers marginalisés et
des phénomènes politiques qui s'y
déroulent et également des enjeux
relatifs au forme de violence politique
et en jeu de sécurité
euh j'ai eu l'occasion finalement de
d'essayer de lire un peu tout ce qui
avait été écrit depuis une quinzaine
d'années sur ce sujet des marginalités
urbaines en France et ailleurs
et ce qui m'a paraît extrêmement
extrêmement frappant à la suite des
événements de l'été
2023 c'est le sentiment finalement de
nouveauté qui animait beaucoup de
réflexions avec l'idée que les
phénomènes qu'on a qualifié d'émeut ou
de violences urbaines auxquell on a été
exposé ont été présentés comme quelque
chose qui sortait de la trame habituelle
de l'ordinaire de la connaissance qu'on
pouvait déjà avoir des enjeux de de
révolte de protestation de violence dans
les quartiers marginalisés et ce
phénomène de nouveauté si je me fais
expression n'est pas nouveau puisque en
2005 on avait déjà présenté les de 2005
comme des émeutes d'un genre nouveau qui
contrastaient avec celle des années 70
ou des années 80 et puis là il y a
l'idée Queen 2023 on a de nouveau une
nouveauté qui se surajoute au fait des é
de 2005 h au cours des 10 dernières
années j'ai été toujours très surpris de
voir combien la mémoire de 2005
finalement était passé quelque
chose d'historique quelque chose qui
était plus un sujet d'actualité qui
appartenait au passé et qui était
finalement une question un petit peu
réglée et euh une difficulté qui étit
passagère qui qui nétait plus au prisme
des priorités politiques ou des enjeux
qui méritaient une attention
particulière et finalement ce qu'on voit
dans le courant de l'été c'est que bien
on remet sur le devant de la scène une
préoccupation pour la situation des
quartiers marginalisés au prisme de ces
violences donc le premier constat que je
ferais c'est que finalement cette
question de la violence et de la
protestation violente elle donne une
existence politique au quartier
marginalisé puisque en l'absence de ces
violences les quartiers marginalisés
n'ont pas véritablement euh de poids
dans les enjeux politiques dans les
débats nationaux euh dans la définition
des politiques publiques euh ou euh dans
la réflexion des questions générales qui
peuvent traverser la société en matière
scolaire en matière de logement en
matière de transport et cetera et
finalement la violence elle fait exister
ces quartiers et leurs habitants dans le
champ politique d'une façon négative
d'une façon qui est souvent perçue comme
stigmatisante ou dévalorisante d'une
façon qui est souvent mal vécue par
beaucoup d'habitants euh mais très
certainement l'existance cette
commission l'existance d'un certain
nombre de commandes euh qui peuvent être
adressées euh à mes collègues
universitaires ou chercheurs montre bien
que il y a un intérêt quand il y a la
violence et quand l'absence de violence
il moins d'intérêt pour ce qui se passe
dans ces quartiers euh ce qui apparaît
également c'est le caractère pluriel de
ces phénomènes euh puisque on a qualifié
comme un ensemble homogène les émeutes
de l'été 2023 euh il semble davantage
qu'on ait une stratification
de différents phénomènes des phénomènes
de réaction immédiates dans les hautes
scènes aux environs de nentire après
euh la mort du jeune naë et puis une
diffusion dans d'autres territoires avec
d'autres modalités d'action par la suite
qui a été interprété comme étant
participant du même mouvement mais en
fait avec des différences de nature de
pratique des différences de répertoire
d'action de mots d'ordre ou voire
parfois d'absence de mots d'ordre qui
viennent questionner finalement l'unité
du phénomène vraisemblable que les
personnes qui se sont affrontées avec
les forces de l'ordre dans les quartiers
marginalisés ont des grilles de lectures
des profils sociologiques des
motivations un peu différentes de celles
qui se sont rendues dans les
centres-villees pour voler des pertes de
basket en cassant des vitrines et donc
le terme d'émeutes à minima recouvre une
diversité de situations et de
configuration qu'il est difficile de
bien documenter parce que on n'a pas de
carte très précise de quel type
d'événement il y a eu dans les
différents territoires donc on a un
cette différence de nature de
l'émot un troisième enjeu qui me paraît
essentiel c'est la question de la
dynamique durable de marginalisation de
certains quartiers euh c'est quelque
chose qui est frappant quand on fait
l'historique de la politique de la ville
sur une quarantaine d'années c'est
combien le constat de tentatives euh
renouvelé et revendiqué à chaque fois
comme ambitieus est suivi d'un constat
d'échec ou en tout cas euh de de succès
très limité euh par rapport à une une
logique de marginalisation qui se
prolonge dans le temps euh dans beaucoup
d'espaces euh qui semble être une
dynamique difficile à enrayer et qui
n'est pas pour autant la dynamique
d'ensemble des grandes métropoles
puisqu'on voit qu'il y a pas du tout une
dualisation entre des quartiers aisés et
des quartiers pauvres mais une majorité
de quartiers qui sont plutôt des
quartiers intermédiaires et mélangés et
localement dans des configurations très
spécifiques des quartiers qui sont
particulièrement marginalisés et qui le
reste durablement et si on prend euh des
dispositifs qui ont 20 ans d'âge il
concernne encore euh la plus plupart de
ces territoires aujourd'hui
h je pense que un des enjeux importants
c'est de déspécialiser le regard sur la
banlieue il y a eu l'idée très fort je
pense après 2005 selon lequel seul
certains quartiers ciblés par des
dispositifs particuliers petique publ
étaient les territoires et les lieux où
résidaient les personnes qui
concentraient le plus de difficultés ce
qui est le cas quand on quand on
objective avec des critères
sociologiques mais on voit bien que
finalement c'est un enjeu qui est un
enjeu national qui concerne des
territoires au-delà des quartiers les
plus marginalisés euh et qui du point de
vue de ses répercussions de ses
conséquences raisonnent à l'échelle du
pays et pas seulement à l'échelle des
banlieux donc je crois pas qu'il y a une
crise des banlieux en tant que telle il
y a des difficultés dans les banlieux
qui provoquent une crise à l'échelle
nationale de la structure des
institutions des politiques publiques et
de la structure du tissu social ou en
tout cas des structures de relations
sociales euh qui sont qui sont présentes
donc euh je pense qu'on peut pas
regarder l' insécurité ou la ségrégation
dans les quartiers marginalisés sans la
regarder en même temps dans des espaces
qui sont également plus aisés parce que
c'est un processus qui est dialectique
et qui finalement
s'alimente de façon de façon
réciproque dans ce processus général un
élément qui me semble mériter
l'attention c'est que lorsque vous
parlez avec des responsables des forces
de l'ordre des services de sécurité vous
indique la préoccupation d'une montée de
la violence en France une montée de la
violence qu'on retrouve pas ou peu dans
la plupart des indateur qu' s'agisse des
statistiques administratives ou des
enquêtes de
victimation mais néanmoins une violence
qui est plus présente dans les conflits
sociaux et on peut présenter des
exemples comme les mouvements
écologistes ou les mouvements autour des
conflits du travail mouvement des
retraites mais on peut penser également
au mouvement des gilets jaunes on a eu
une succession de mouvements sociaux
dans lesquels la violence était
finalement à un moment ou un autre une
facette du rapport politique en
l'absence d'autres relais d'autres
médiations institutionnelles je crois
que la question des ban lieu est une
question paroxistique de cette dynamique
en l'absence quasi complète de relais
politiqu structurés finalement il n'y a
soit pas de confrontation soit une
confrontation qui passe par la forme de
la violence et qui est un des enjeux à
construire et qui pas forcément
seulement du travail des institutions
mais c'est de réussir à trouver des
canaux de désaccord et d'affrontement
politique qui ne passent pas par la
violence et qui permettent de faire
émerger des enjeux de façon beaucoup
plus structurelle que ces affrontements
sporadiques qui arrivent voilà à
échéance régulière et en causant
beaucoup de dégâts et et beaucoup de
dommage aussi pour les auteurs pour
certains très jeune dont la trajectoire
sociale scolaire familiale va être
fortement impactée par leur
participation et leur condamnation dans
ces
contextes peut-être pour pour en
terminer avant de passer la parole à mes
collègue je crois qu'il y a un enjeu
également très important sur la
réflexion avec avec les forces de
l'ordre et la relation à la police il y
a eu le sentiment peut-être de mettre en
cause uniquement les responsabilité
individuelle des agents de police euh ce
qui est effectivement une partie
importante puisqu'ils ont la détention
moyen de répression et que leur usage
dépend de de leur exercice personnel
mais qu'il y a sans doute aussi des
questions de doctrine sur les modalités
et la présence euh des forces de
sécurité dans un certain nombre de
quartiers et c'est spectaculaire quand
on regarde sur une vingtaine d'années ce
débat sur euh les modalités précises
d'existence la police de proximité puis
sa suppression puis son retour et on
voit bien qu'on est finalement dans une
oscillation des dispositifs euh sans euh
lignes directrices vraiment
structurelles sur le long terme je crois
que un des grands enjeux si on veut euh
voir un développement euh de ces
quartiers marginalisés et les voir
réduire l'écart avec le reste de la
société française euh c'est sans doute
dans le besoin d'ancrer sur le long
terme un certain nombre de dispositifs
et de ne pas avoir ces fluctuations euh
qui sont souvent euh souvent peu
productives un dernier mot peut-être sur
des territoires qui sont très très peu
évoqués mais qui me paraissent mériter
une attention particulière au regard des
indicateurs socio-démographiques qu'il
présente ce sont les territoires
ultramarins euh dans lesquels il y a des
formes de marginalité qui sont très très
intenses euh mais qui passent souvent un
peu au second plan euh des enjeux des
dispositifs de politique publique euh
également parce que ce sont des
territoires qu'on a moins bien
documentés que ce soit dans les données
de ress ou dans les données d'enquêre de
victimation depuis les dernières années
donc il y a une volonté de mieux prendre
en compte ces territoires mais je crois
que c'est un enjeu important qui passe
un peu trop souvent au second
plan merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
jardin monsieur merk par que je vois
plus nos interlocuteurs en visio c'est
normal ils ont disparuz-y monsieur
mer remerci monsieur le
[Musique]
Président
alors dans la
l'invitation que je remercie la
convocation à venir aujourd'hui parmi
vousation conv pas c'est une invitation
merci je vous en remercie quand même
et on
[Musique]
m'a précisément demandé de de
d'intervenir autour des des équipements
publics des équipements culturels euh
qui ont été pris par cible lors des
manifestations et qui et à propos
desquelles j'ai enquêté pendant très
longtemps alors je vais essayer de
donner un certain nombre d'éléments
permettant de de construire une certaine
intelligibilité parce que les attaques à
ces
équipements provoquent souvent une une
perplexité que ce soit de la part des
des personnels des des bibliothèques par
exemple ou des élus euh des instances
ministérielles et puis de de l'opinion
publique en
général le ce que je vais présenter et
trouve sa source dans un
travail de terrain de longue haline des
de nombreuses enquêtes qui se succède et
donc une temporalité qui est qui est
nécessaire et qui est précise ce
pourquoi aussi d'une certaine façon de
mon pour ce que je peux faire les
émeutes du mois de juin sont encore
faiblement connu on les on en connaît
très peu
de du point de vue de des enquêtes que
je peux mener
euh il y a quand même un certain nombre
d'élément on a évoqué à l'instant cette
question de la nouveauté et de la et et
de la
continuité de ce type de de
manifestation et la la la focale doit
être large
et considérer l'ensemble des acteurs qui
sont qui sont engagés dans dans le
conflit ou dans la conflictualité que le
M met en
scène l'une des choses qui est qui qui
est une nouveauté qui est évidente ne se
trouve nullement dans les quartiers mais
ailleurs on vient de de d'exprimer le
caractère politique dans
l'intelligibilité dans la compréhension
de ce type de phénomène en 2005 on en on
disait exactement le contraire qui un
déficit de socialisation politique que
c'était des actes nilistes que c'était
des actes à l'extérieur de la
citoyenneté que tout ça s'expliquait
comme une forme de pousser des
sentiments de broncas de de
de de manque de de rationalité et
aujourd'hui on est passé
euh heureusement je crois à une analyse
complètement différente qui qui qui
donne à voir ces manifestations comme
des mouvements sociaux comme des
manifestations sociales comme des formes
de mobilisation qui donnent une forme de
la politique une un changement dans la
la l'expérience de la
citoyenneté et de notre vie démocratique
qu'elle soit à caractère négative ou
positive c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
au sociologue peut-être de le de le de
le qualifier d'une d'une manière ou de
l'autre j'ai essayé
de
de faire de cette question une question
centrale des mes objets de recherche je
proposé pour cela
un une notion qui est celle de la
politicité populaire qui essae de de
rendre compte du fait que l'expérience
de la citoyenneté n'est pas la même
selon les groupes sociaux ça paraît une
évidence mais il faut le rappeler à
chaque fois et cette expérience à voir
avec le type de conflit dans lequel
chaque groupe est est prend part d'une
part et euh et donc elle se distingue
de par exemple la citoyen l'expérience
de la citoyenneté des classes moyennes
mais aussi d'autres segments des classes
populaires et c'est l'un des élément sur
lequel je vais revenir à l'instant et
deuxièmement le fait que cette
expérience de la citoyenneté ou cette
politicité évolue dans le temps et
[Musique]
euh pour saisir
euh ce qui se passe dans les quartiers
populaires il faut avoir une attention
particulière à la relation ou au rapport
des habitants et du groupe c'est pas
pareil le groupe que les personnes ou
les familles avec les institutions parce
que il y a une spécificité
euh française pas exclusivement
française mais pour pour des gens qui
travaillent aussi ou qui enquêtent dans
d'autres horizons quand on fait quand on
mène une démarche
comparative dans d'A dans des sociétés à
caractère plus libéral ou dans des
sociétés plus pauvres comme celle
d'Amérique du Nord par exemple ou dans
des sociétés plus pauvres où où l'État a
un caractère
segmentaire
uncertain la la où l'État social est
moins fréquemment Pr
ce qui caractérise un quartier populaire
c'est l'absence de
l'État en France ce qui caractérise la
vie des habitants des quartiers
populaires c'est l'omniprésence de
l'État il faut s'interroger très
précisément pour la à propos de la
manière dont ces familles et ces et ces
personnes trouvent solution à la plupart
des problèmes qui concerne la vie
quotidienne qui est la leure l'éducation
la santé le logement la culture le sport
les
transports euh tout cela et plus est
entre les mains d'institutions publiques
et C expérience de la vie quotidienne
c'est-à-dire le fait que les problèmes
ne trouvent pas leur solution ni par la
solidarité locale ni dans le marché en
payant avec son salaire des services par
exemple ou en accédant à des biens avec
son salaire fait que il il y a une
conflictualité qui est directement
politique la vie quotidienne de ces
personnes est directement politisée
parce que ils sont en conflit récurrent
et quotidien avec un fonctionnaire un
agent représentant de l'institution qui
prend des décisions et qui est un
fonctionnaire un membre de la fonction
publique derrière lequel se trouvent les
autorités les élus le personnel
politique et donc il y a une
politisation immédiate euh de la
conflictualité sociale et ça c'est une
note majeure
euh une coordonnée principale euh à
l'intérieur de laquelle se trouvent les
équipements culturels deème et je vais y
revenir plus précisément mais deuxème
élément sur lequel je voudlais attirer
l'attention c'est sur ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'historicité de l'émeut
l'historicité est double d'une part et
ça a été rappelé
c'est une histoire qui commence disons
en 1979 ou au début des des années des
années 80 et où on observe de de cette
relative unité des classes populaires en
France autour de la classe ouverrière le
détachement d'un segment d'une partie
qui se manifeste par l'émergence d'un
nouveau répertoire de l'action
collective pour pour ce qui relève de
notre jargon de de ceux qui faisons de
la sociologie politique c'est-à-dire les
gens commencent à agir collectivement
autrement que par le passé ce n'est plus
la manifestation le vote et la grève qui
sont les modes d'expression naturel ou
primordiaux de ces de ces groupes à
travers les syndicats et les partis
politiques qui assurent l'intégration et
la socialisation politique c'est donc
les meutes le monde associatif qui a été
suscité et euh créé suite à la réponse
de l'État à ces émeutes les lois de
décentralisation et la création de la
politique de la ville qui fait exister
une myiade d'associations dans tout le
territoire et en militantisme très
important quand on interroge aujourd'hui
les membres qui ont 40 50 ans de ces
associations qui sont indispensables à
la vie démocratique et bien on
s'aperçoit que beaucoup parmi eux
étaient des émetiers par exemple il y a
20 ans parce que ça dure depuis 40 ans
et cette cette cette historicité est est
très importante cette dimension de
l'historicité est très très importante
mais il y en a une autre dimension de
l'historicité qui est celle de
l'événement et la la manière dont on
découpe l'événement dont
on la manière comment qu'on va employer
pour circoncrire l'événement est très
importante est-ce que ça commence avec
la mort d'un jeune dans le dans un
conflit avec la police dans l'immense
majorité des cas suivi d'une é meute et
suivi d'une inscription dans l'espace
public qui est primordiale l'émeut a un
caractère éminemment symbolique ce n'est
pas l'instauration d'une d'un rapport de
force qu'on cherche mais la possibilité
d'inscrire dans l'espace politique local
ou national en fonction des
circonstance un événement c'est-à-dire
de susciter la prise de
parole c'est ça ça c'est le noyau de
l'historicité et il y a un moment en
aval et un moment en amont de de
l'événement en aval c'est une
conflictualité sourde silencieuse et
cachée que justement les maîes cherchent
à faire venir dans l'espace public et il
y en a une autre en amant ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui fait partie de
l'événement euh heureusement fait
intervenir d'autres acteurs la presse
les sciences sociales les autorités qui
vont se prononcer qui vont prendre la
paroles qui vont qualifier les faits qui
vont qualifier les protagonistes et qui
vont de ce fait donner euh son caractère
politique l'inscrire dans la dans dans
la vie du système politique l'une des
clés d'interprétation de l'émeut c'est
la cupure qu'il y a entre les espaces de
paroles à l'extérieur de l'institution à
l'extérieur de l'espace du système
politique et ce qui peut venir à
l'intérieur par exemple les incendies
des bibliothèques que j'ai étudié en
2005 je trouve 70 incendies des
bibliothèques depuis les années 80 il y
a jamais eu un article de presse
là-dessus jamais une prise de parole
jamais un débat politique concernant
l'incendie d'une bibliothèque on aurait
pu penser que dans un pays comme la
France la mise à feu d'une bibliothèque
aurait pu sciter une grande émotion ça
n'a pas été le cas aujourd'hui il y a
des articles dans la presse la
télévision s'y intéresse je suis ici
pour en parler il y a un changement ça
c'est le moment qui suit les
meut pour finir et dire un mot des
bibliothèques et et des équipements
culturels les Bibl donc auintègre font
partie de ce de cet appareil
institutionnel qui fait les quartiers
qui les produit du logement jusqu'à la
bibliothèque en passant par les terrains
des sports les écoles et cetera et de ce
fait le bibliothécaire fait parti d'une
chaîne d'agents qui se trouve face aux
habitants comme étant
euh une association du même une
association du même qui va qui qui donne
son même caractère à l'instituteur au
bibliothécaire à l'agent de la fice HLM
de la PMI et le policier et donc il y a
de ce fait une face à un face à-face qui
se produit entre des agents et des
habitants qui sont eux deux mis par
l'État et par la situation sociale au
cœur d'une conflictualité qui trouve
souvent ses causes ailleurs donc il
n'est pas il n'est absolument pas
étonnant que le conflit se prenne les
institutions comme cible de la
manifestation même lorsque c'est un
policier qui se trouve à l'origine ou en
conflit avec la police et qu'on va
brûler une bibliothèque quand on regarde
les choses de ce point de vue-là on voit
que la bibliothèque ce n'est plus une
bibliothèque populaire qui trouve son
origine dans une émergence dans les
habitants qui s'organisent pour créer un
espace de réflexion pour créer un lieu
d'émancipation mais une implantation du
service public qui vient là pour aider
les habitants individuellement mais qui
a énormément de mal à parler au groupe à
participer du groupe d'où la question
récurrente est-ce leur bibliothèque ou
notre bibliothèque c'est ça la question
que se posent les habitants et la pierre
jeté vient interroger l'institution pour
lui dire alors tu es notre institution
ou la leure l'écrit de ce point de vue
se pose dans l'espace d'une ralité où
c'est le sacré de l'autre qu'on va
essayer de busculer parce que c'est
l'écrit le terrain de l'école du marché
du travail qui nous est scamoté la
parole de la vie politique de la vie
institutionnelle et c'est tout cela qui
est mise en question à travers la pierre
et le feu en essayant de rendre visible
cette problématique qui a du mal à être
dite les habitants eux-mêmes les les
émetiers eux-mêmes ont énormément de mal
à pouvoir transformer cette action
symbolique en une action une action
textuelle discursive avec une parole
permettant de la rendre intelligible par
elle-même c'est à nous de le faire voilà
merci de votre attention merci beaucoup
monsieur alors je me retourne vers nos
intervenants qui sont en visio monsieur
Domingo et Monsieur dub y a-t-il une
préférence pour intervenir ou
d'autorité et bien écoutez le premier de
maist c'estur monsieur Domingo alors
vous avez la
parole bonjour merci pour pour votre
invitation donc moi je vous parle depuis
depuis la province et depuis une ville
qui est la ville de Toulouse
euh qui a subi là aussi depuis une
vingtaine
d'années ces phénomènes que l'on
qualifie d'émeutes ou de violences
urbaines notamment en
1998 à à la
suite de la mort d'un dénommé Pipo donc
un jeune qui est mort là aussi dans une
dans une altercation avec la police et
qui a donné lieu à à des émeutes sur la
ville et qui a enclenché d'ailleurs par
la suite la mise en place d'un d'un
dispositif qui était émergent à l'époque
qui était celui des contrats locaux de
sécurité donc l'idée qu'il fallait
traiter de manière partenariale euh pas
seulement policière d'ailleurs euh ces
enjeux euh ces enjeux de quartier euh
avec finalement l'émeut qui va donner
naissance à faire une mobilisation de
dispositifs publics essayant de voilà de
renforcer l'action publique sur ces
quartiers qui sont à Toulouse et les
quartiers notamment d' du grandmail et
qui en effet comme d'autres dans la
région parisienne ou en province sont
parfois affectés par par ces phénomènes
euh alors je vais essayer de sans trop
répéter ce qu'on dit mes collègues mais
c'est vrai souligner l'historicité de de
de ce phénomène d' métier ou de violence
urbaines qui alterne entre des fortes
continuités mais aussi des des formes
d'innovation et de nouveauté euh les
continuité euh
elle s'inscrivent un effet dans dans une
histoire qui a qui a au moins une
quarantaine d'années en tout cas si on
prend le le début de la réflexion sur
sur la question des quartiers avec
l'émergence de la politique de la ville
donc depuis le début des des années 80
François dub je penseon pourra y revenir
parce qu'il a il a travaillé ça depuis
de très nombreuses années
mais donc on est dans une forme de de
grande continuité avec des événements
notamment en 2006 une forme de
récurrence de ces événements qui en font
finalement désormais non plus des
événements exceptionnels mais des
événements qui se reproduisent selon une
forme de régularité plus ou moins
importante et qui se rappelle à nous
dans ce qui est finalement la question
sociale de ces quartiers euh c'est ces
émeutes ces violences urbaines elles
résultent souvent d'ailleurs de d'un
événement déclencheur
souvent lié à une altercation entre la
police et des jeunes avec parfois la
mort la mort d'un jeune qui va générer
en tout cas l'étincelle
euh qui va mettre le feu au poudre euh
et créer une forme de déstabilisation
plus collective du quartier et puis
ensuite du une forme de diffusion sur le
territoire national donc là aussi on a
parmi les continuités on l'a vu
finalement il y a un certain nombre de
quartiers qui qui restent des des
quartiers dissensibles malgré ces 40 ans
de politique de la ville avec là aussi
une population celle des jeunes issus de
ces quartiers euh qui sont des quartiers
popérisé des jeunes qui font
l'expérience plus ou moins conscientisé
d'ailleurs plus ou moins politique de
certaines formes d'inégalité de
marginalisation sociale et d'une
expérience qui est à la fois objective
mais aussi subjective je pense qu'il
faut réintégrer la la dimension
subjective les perceptions sociales que
peuvent avoir certains jeunes de leur de
leur position sociale des inégalités
qu'ils subissent les enjeux de
reconnaissance euh donc des des jeunes
qui se
sentent marginalisés victimes
d'inégalité alors parfois souvent à
raison hein mais aussi parfois avec des
formes de distorsion peut-être de
représentation qu'il qu'il possède et
qui les font euh se sentir exclus euh
d'un système auquel il pensent ne pas
appartenir et donc ce qui questionne
directement ce ce lien de citoyenneté ce
lien civique euh que l'on invoque
souvent mais qu'on a du mal à à inscrire
dans une forme de matérialité et de
subjectivité plus
quotidienne la l'autre élément l'autre
continuité c'est l'attaque contre les
équipements les incendies de véhicules
les affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre le la destruction ça a été dit
des écoles des bibliothèques des
équipements publics qui représentent
l'état autre continuité c'est celle de
la en tout cas de la logique de
diffusion sur le territoire national qui
fait que l' meut c'est à la fois un
phénomène local mais c'est aussi un
phénomène national et un phénomène
partagé alors parmi finalement les les
nouveautés à mon avis qui sont celles
des émeutes de de
2023 c'est d'abord
la la rapidité de la contagion euh de de
ce ces émeutes et puis euh la rapidité
de
leur de leur fin
puisque elles ont duré finalement assez
assez peu de temps donc on est sur une
forme d'embrasement très fort et avec
une forte mobilisation d'ailleurs de
dispositifs de maintien de l'ordre et
une réponse judiciaire qui a été très
très rapide également qui nous montre à
la fois je pense un un phénomène qui euh
qui est lui aussi donc qui tient la la
qui tient aussi à la volatilité
peut-être du mouvement euh qui est
finalement moins organisé je pense qu'on
ne le dit euh parce qu'il est le
résultat de de la coalition de petits
groupes de jeunes qui sont là aussi
parfois par opportunisme euh avec une
parfois peut-être une charge politique
qui est beaucoup plus faible que
précédemment on parle de la question de
la mobilisation du mouvement social bon
je pense que cette question du mouvement
social elle est elle est toujours là
hein en filigrane mais peut-être par
rapport aux nouvelles générations de ces
jeunes qui s'engagent dans ces dans ces
dynamiques là euh on a une population
peut-être aussi beaucoup plus
diversifiée avec des agendas beaucoup
plus hétérogènes
euh on a aussi sûrement une une présence
en tout cas ressentie plus forte des
violences à la fois du côté des
hémetiers mais aussi du côté de la répon
de la réponse policière en tout cas la
perception de la violence elle est
beaucoup plus forte elle est aussi mise
en scène dans les médias de manière
beaucoup plus explicite et donc sans
doute ressenti beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus fortement au niveau des
subjectivités à la fois des forces de
l'ordre et des et des jeunes euh avec
quelques quand même événements qui
peuvent questionner moi ce qui
m'a quand même alerté c'est l'attaque
par exemple de la prison de freine par
des groupes donc on est je pense que
dans les précédentes émeutes on avait
pas constaté l'attaque d'une prison
l'attaque directe contre certains élus
donc des signes qui montrent en effet
des alors ils sont des signes émergents
peut-être pas donc sur lesquels il faut
je pense être vigilant et qui questionne
ce rapport à la violence et et la
confrontation directe là cette fois-ci
avec les les représentants de l'État
euh finalement une des notes une des
nouveautés aussi c'est la la question du
pillage euh on a vu dans cette dernière
séquence d'émeut que euh finalement
lesmeut constitue aussi un espace
d'action pour pour aller piller des des
supermarchés des centres-villees des
magasins donc dans une logique et
finalement alors qu'on peut qualifier de
politique hein mais qui est aussi
finalement plus peut-être pour certains
acteurs moins formalisés selon ce mode
et qui relève du fait que l'on se
profite de l'émeut pour se
servir et pour bénéficier finalement du
de ce que de ce qu'offre la société
capitaliste dans une logique qui est qui
est tout à fait instrumentale autre
élément aussi qui me paraît assez
nouveau ou en tout cas qui se renforce
c'est la question de la médiatisation
euh via les réseaux sociaux euh qui
n'existait pas de manière aussi forte et
aussi aussi importante à l'époque et qui
permet aux jeunes finalement de produire
leurs propres images de l'émeut et donc
je pense qu'on a pas encore très bien
compris comment tout ça fonctionnait à
la fois dans la diffusion de l'émeut
dans le partage d'expérience réciproque
chez chez ces jeunes dans l'émulation
résulté et dans la spectacularisation de
de l'émeut voir dans la jouissance tout
simplement euh de ce partage de ce
partage d'une expérience collective au
niveau local mais aussi au niveau
national
euh donc je reviendrai sur ce qui a été
aussi dit finalement c'est que ces
émeutes de 2023 elles sont peut-être
plus composites qu'on le dit euh elles
ont une dimension pour certains acteurs
sans doute jeune qui qui qui n qui peut
renvoyer une lecture politique hein la
la mort du jeune Naël en eff faet aire
renvoie un questionnement sur le rapport
aux institutions à la police ça c'est je
pense qu' un élément important mais dans
sa diffusion je pense que le mouvement
devient aussi de plus en plus hétérogène
il devient parfois des
fouloirs espace de confrontation et
parfois pour certains acteurs peut-être
plus organisés comme certains
trafiquants de drogue c'est une manière
de mettre en difficulté les autorités
publiques auxquels elles sont
confrontées au fil du au fil des
jours deux points encore peut-être je
sais pas s'il me reste un petit peu de
temps euh je pense qu' ce qui est
important c'est d'abord de repenser
peut-être dans le le volet solution
quelque chose qui est souvent mis de
côté c'est ce lien entre la jeunesse des
quartiers populaires et la police donc
on tourne beaucoup autour du débat mais
on on a peu de de de solution assez
directe qui remettrait en effet qui
renvoerit une doctrine précise de
prévention du rôle préventif de la
police dans dans ces quartiers euh et ça
cette doctrine là elle est souvent
renvoyée d'ailleurs aux acteurs sociaux
en disant la police fait son travail les
acteurs sociaux do et donc on est dans
une forme de de répartition des rôles
qui à mon avis est pas forcément
toujours bonne parce qu'elle renvoie à
du coup à une forme de
conflictualisation entre ces jeunes et
la police et avec l'enjeu aujourd'hui à
mon avis qui qui qui est sous-estimé du
rôle des polices municipales qui se sont
beaucoup structurés au cours des
dernières années et qu'on doit
aujourd'hui faire rentrer dans
l'équation et qui ces polices
municipales souvent qui miment sont dans
une forme de mimétisme institutionnel
sur le plan culturel et et des mot
d'action avec avec la police nationale
et donc là aussi euh je pense qu'il faut
repenser le rôle des polices locales en
lien avec celui de la gendarmerie ou des
polices de la police nationale sur la
manière dont se crée ce ce rapport
police population ce qui renvoie des
enjeux de formation des policiers
nationaux de la gendarmerie nationale
mais aussi des polices municipales et
comme cela a été dit aussi sur les
enjeux les les médiations que l'on peut
organiser entre ces deux entre les
jeunes et la police alors sachant qu'il
y a quand même des expériences qui sont
qui existent hein comme les
correspondants police population les
centres de loisirs jeunes gérés par la
police nation national mais euh voilà
qu'il faudrait sans doute approfondir et
pour pour pouvoir avoir une lecture plus
préventive de de l'activité policière
qui soit pas seulement lorsqu'il y a des
émeutes centrés sur les enjeux de
maintien de l'ordre le le second point
c'est qu'il faut qu'on arrive à mieux
comprendre les nouvelles subjectivité
juvénil he le leur transformation les
politicisation ordinaire qui existent
chez ces chez ces jeunes et peut-être on
s beaucoup je pense centré sur les
publics adolescents et puis sur les plus
jeunes je pense qu'il faut on voit que
dans ces émeutes on a beaucoup de de 18
de 18 25 ans donc les les jeunes adultes
et cette catégorie des des jeunes
adultes on les on les aborde souvent en
effet par le BIA de l'intégration
socio-économique et c'est un point
important mais il faut aussi peut-être
les les reprendre le reprendre le débat
à partir de leurs besoins politiques et
des canaux d'expression politique qui
peuvent exister euh qu'on peut mettre à
leur disposition et là je pense qu'on
est un peu en déficite avec des enjeux
aussi intergénérationnels euh comme ça a
été dit hein ces jeunes aujourd'hui sont
parfois les enfants des Meutiers et donc
avec des transmissions
intergénérationnelles dans les familles
qu'on pe peut-être qu'on peine à avec
des choses qui qui ont été transmis et
qu'on peine à à comprendre aujourd'hui
le dernier point à mon avis qui qui est
important c'est de travailler sur les
mécanismes de prévention du phénomène
euh on a une politique de la ville qui
se relance on a une politique nationale
de prévention d' l'incrance qui va se
relancer en 2024 donc c'est comment on
fait comment on intègre ces enjeux de la
prévention dispositif préventif on peut
intégrer dans ces politiques publiques
là et on se rend compte que la question
hémeutière elle est jamais prise en
compte par ces politiques de prévention
de la délinquance euh quand on reprend
les différents textes depuis une
vingtaine d'années qui essaient de de
cadrer ces objectifs de prévention de la
délinquance la question hmeutière elle
est pas présente en tout cas pas
directement et dans la politique de la
ville finalement la politique de la
ville est plus vue plutôt comme une
sorte de correctif social qui
permettrait de de prévenir de nouveaux
mouvement on voit bien que tout ça reste
malgré tout difficile
euh et pour produire des effets donc ce
qui renvoie aussi à des enjeux
d'évaluation pas seulement national mais
aussi local et d'animation de la manière
dont on anime et on met en œuvre ces
dispositifs local avec sans doute des
enjeux de
débureaucratisation de cette politique
de la ville et de ces dispositifs qui
sont très nombreux et qui rendent
finalement les choses assez lisible
illisible pardon en terme de contrat
social donc il y a peut-être un travail
sur la manière dont l'état finalement
principalement euh et les en lien avec
les collectivités locales définit ses
politiques et les animes voilà je pense
queoupoup merci Monsieur Domingo merci
beaucoup on va donner la parole à
Monsieur François Dubet alors c'est
pareil est-ce que je le
vois je ne le vois
plus je ne sais pas moi je vous je vous
vois je vous je vous entends bien
parfait ben écoutez Monsieur Vous AVEZ
LA
PAROLE bien alors comme ça déjà a été
évoqué j'ai j'ai le triste privilège de
l'âge c'est-à-dire d'avoir ir étudier
les émeutes du début des années
80 et je je crois qu'il faut d'abord un
peu comprendre que c'est à la fois des
révoltes quant à leur signification et
des émeutes par leur mode d'action après
tout une révolte contre des injustices
vécues pourrait donner lieu à des
manifestations des grèves autre chose
que des émeutes mais le vocabulaire
lui-même nous met dans dans une sorte
d'incertitude alors moi ce qui me frappe
c'est c'est quand même la répétition je
veux dire que c'est la répétition sur le
sentiment de discrimination d'injustice
de chômage de mise à l'écart et cetera
bon il y a ce sont des choses
extrêmement connues c'est le
déclenchement quasi automatique ou quasi
régulier par une confrontation avec la
police c'est la disparition des acteurs
locaux c'est très spectaculaire et ça
date depuis les années 80 c'est-à-dire
que le maire disparaît le le les
travailleurs sociaux dispara a les
enseignants disparaissent il n'y a plus
rien c'est un vide politique qui qui qui
s'installe c'est la répression c'est le
retour au calme c'est les réactions
politiques assez convenues les uns
disent c'est d'abord une révolte les
autres donc c'est un problème de justice
sociale les autres disent c'est d'abord
un problème de maintien de l'ordre donc
un problème de police et je partage ce
qui a été dit c'estàdire qu'on a été
plus habile pour faire des politiques de
la que pourraitformer l'action policière
je ferme cette parenthèse depuis une
quarantaine d'années alors évidemment
chaque fois qu'il y a des émeut on
explique que c'est pas comme la dernière
fois mais c'est en réalité assez assez
proche ce qui a changé a déjà été
souligné c'est-à-dire que par la grâce
des réseaux sociaux il y a un phénomène
traîné de poudre qui est extrêmement
spectaculaire dans la dernière émeute on
a vu des villes toutes petites dans
lesquelles on n'imaginait pas qu'il y
aurait des meut dans lesquels les jeunes
sont entrés dans des sortes de jeu de
concurrence avec d'autres parce que tout
ça était sur la toile
euh je crois que la grande
caractéristique c'est au fond que la
seule émute qui a créé un mouvement ça a
été on en fait aujourd'hui le 40e
anniversaire ça a été la marche pour
l'égalité contre le racisme parce qu'il
y avait des acteurs locaux parce qu'il y
avait des travailleurs sociaux parce
qu'il y avait un curé parce qu'il y
avait une oreille politique alors le
destin de cette marche est une autre
affaire mais en tout cas on était dans
une logique démocratique au fond où une
révolte se transformer en mouvement
social en
revendication ce qui me paraît
caractéristique évidemment et et au fond
le plus tragique c'est c'est que ce cet
embrayage qui passe du sentiment
d'injustice et de révolte à l'action
organisé politique revendicative qui est
quand même au cœur des mécanismes
démocratiques la démocratie ça consiste
à transformer des révoltes en
revendication euh donc à pacifier la vie
sociale là c'est quelque chose qui de
toute évidence patine depuis depuis des
années et je crois même que c'est de
pire en pire parce qu'au fond ces
émeutes sont de plus en plus le prétexte
à des interprétations exogènes c'est
l'immigration c'est l'envahissement
c'est le capitalisme c'est le
néocapitalisme et au fond personne
n'écoute les gens c'est ça qui me frappe
et euh personne au fond ça a déjà été
dit ne on nentend jamais les habitants
de ces quartiers qui sont des problèmes
sociaux qui ne sont pas des acteurs
sociaux donc je crois que ce qu'il y a
de de plus pénible au fond c'est la
répétition de ce genre de d'affaire et
au fond son son
extension alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé je crois que la France a été dans
une situation paradoxale depuis une
trentaine d'années il y a eu des
politiques de la ville qui n'ont pas
été inefficaces qui ça n'a pas été rien
je veux dire que dans ma bonne ville de
Bordeaux j'ai vu des quartiers se
transformer être plus vivable plus on a
créer des trames des bus on a mis des
équipements enfin ça n'est pas et ça ça
a beaucoup frappé j'y reviendrai les les
journalistes étrangers que qui m'ont qui
m'ont interrogé était très surpris par
la alors je vais en avec tous les tous
les guillemets du monde mais par la
qualité du bâti d'un certain nombre de
banlieux qui s'enflamment et qui qui
disent je comprends on comprend pas
vraiment pourquoi dans ces endroits qui
sont au fond qui sont plus du tout des
grands ais urbains on on a des révoltes
je crois que ce qui a ce qui a été la
faiblesse de ces politiques c'est que
ces politiques là n'ont pas
affecter un mécanisme que je crois on
peut définir de la manière suivante
c'est qu'au fond dans ces
quartiers tous ceux qui s'en sortent et
beaucoup s'en sortent de ces quartiers
s'en vont les fuit il y a une mobilité
sociale et cette mobilité sociale joue
contre le quartier au
fond j'y reviendrai quand on quand on
regarde ce qui était les banlieux
populaires les grands ensembles les
banlieux roues euh qui ont existé
jusqu'au début des années 80 il y avait
des classe moyenne les enseignants
vivaient là les travailleurs sociaux
vivaient là les jeunes ménages en
mobilité vivaient là alors
évidemment il y avait de la distance
sociale entre les habitants mais c'est
ce qu'on appelle la mixité il y avait il
n avait il y avait des travailleurs bien
installés des classes moyennes et cetera
aujourd'hui le mécanisme de peuplement
des quartiers est un mécanisme qui fait
que tous ceux qui s'en sortent s'en vont
et sont remplacés par des gens de plus
en plus pauvre et qui viennent de plus
en plus loin et donc vous avez une sorte
de paradoxe entre une action sur le
cadre qui est loin d'être insignifiante
et une incapacité de de de d'agir sur un
peuplement qui fait que ça s'appauvrit
et que c'est de plus en plus un monde
éloigné immigré étranger
bon ça c'est évidemment un mécanisme qui
accentue considérablement le sentiment
de de euh de marginalisation d'exclusion
puisque la mobilité des uns euh de la
mobilité des un découle l'enfermement
des autres ENF vous avez m comme ça il y
a un mot en France qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à utiliser qui est le mot ghetto
euh alors il est évident que si on
compare les quartiers français au grands
getau du Sud du Sud de Chicago et cetera
c'est pas comparable mais quand même si
les quartiers ne sont pas des ghettos il
y a des mécanismes de ghetto dans le
quartier c'est-à-dire que ça c'est ce
qui me frappe sur l'observation des
quartiers que j'ai bien connu et que
dans lesquels je continue d'aller c'est
que ces quartiers se sontent enfermés
ces quartiers ont été enfermés ou exclus
on pourrait dire par les politiques de
peuplement en fait pas par les
politiques par les mécanismes de
peuplement de plus en plus pauvr de plus
en plus euh il suffit de regarder
d'ailleurs l'évolution des indices de
position social des collèges pour voir
que l'écart se creuse avec le le reste
de de de la ville et on sait tous quand
on est sociologue et c'est très
désagréable que quand le ghto est
fortement constitué du dehors par
l'exclusion les stigmat la mise à
l'écart et cetera il finit par se
construire du dedans et il y a quand
même beaucoup de travaux qui montrent
que
que le ghetto devient au fond une forme
de vie collective où on est entre soi où
on contrôle il y a beaucoup d'enquêtes
qui ont été faites là-dessus on finit
par contrôler l'espace par contrôler les
filles par
contrôler par se surveiller par faire
que le jeu des réputations vous enferme
et donc d'une certaine manière le
quartier est à la fois ce qui vous
exclut mais en même temps ce qui peut en
tout cas chez les jeunes vous donner une
identité par des mécanismes de
renversement de
fierté voilà et d'ailleurs quand le
ghetto est extrêmement
constitué on peut observer que le le
développement des trafics procède du
ghetto et
le je dirais et l'organise alors il
s'agit pas de donner dans la littérature
des romans Nar des
romans disons dans les films de SCOR on
est peut-être pas là mais des élus
marseillais me faisaient remarquer que
dans les quartiers les plus ségrégués de
la ville il y avait pas d'émeut parce
que la logique du trafic fait qu'on
souhaite pas vraiment qu' a des émeutes
donc d'une certaine manière vous avez
un un renfermement et et et au fond moi
j'ai beaucoup étudié le système scolaire
il y a un moment où vous êtes victime de
l'échec scolaire et un moment où au fond
l'échec scolaire devient votre identité
contre
l'école ça ça a été très très bien
étudié je le signale aux États-Unis dans
des comparaisons qui ont été faites il y
a assez longtemps entre les migrants
volontaires c'est-à-dire les gens qui
venaient aux États-Unis pour y vivre et
pour s'y installer et dont les enfants
réussissaient assez bien à l'école alors
qu'il venaient de très loin alors que
les minorités involontaires
c'est-à-dire les les les afrois
Américains installés là depuis longtemps
stigmatisés enfermés avaent des
résultats scolaires plus faibles parce
parce qu'il ne croyit pas à l'école et
parce que l'école ne croyait pas qu'il
pourrait y réussir donc d'une certaine
manière vous avez des des des des des
des il faut regarder ça je crois un peu
en face des moments où le quartier finit
par s'enfermer sur sur lui-même en tout
cas pas tous les habitants du quartier
bien évidemment mais dans une large
mesure dans une large mesure les jeunes
et moi qui me suis beaucoup intéressé au
problèmes scolaires on le VO très bien à
l'école vous avez aujourd'hui y compris
dans ces quartiers des mécanismes de
fuite de l'école du quartier du collège
du quartier par ceux qui le peuvent où
les gens vous disent je suis déjà
enfermé dans le quartier je ne souhaite
pas être enfermé dans le collège du
quartier donc je vais aller à côté et
donc je vais fabriquer le
getto d'une certaine manière dont je
suis victime enfin je je crois qu'il
faut bien comprendre la force de ces
mécanismes parce que il sera pas facile
de les de les de
les de les contrer mais chacun d'entre
nous connaît une ville dans laquelle il
y a au moins un ou deux quartiers il
s'agit pas forcément une très grande
ville qui est complètement dans cette
logique d'autau d'exclusion radicale et
d'auto-enfermement en tout cas des
jeunes des jeunes du
quartier ça je crois que c'est le le le
grand problème que nous avons c'est
qu'au fond nos qu urbaines n'ont
pas pas pesé sur le peuplement
des des des quartiers et la mobilité
sociale que nous désirons tous joue
plutôt contre ces quartiers dans
lesquels j'y reviendrai vous ne trouvez
plus d'enseignants qui vivent de
travailleurs sociaux qui y vivent de
militants qui y vivent tous ces tous ces
acteurs qui étaient les vecteurs d'une
transformation de la révolte en
revendication qui avait une capacité
politique ont disparu dans beaucoup
d'endroits où je suis allé les gens vous
disent c'est le collège des
Français parce que les enseignants sont
français de leur point de vue eux aussi
le sont ne ne vivent pas dans le
quartier ne sont pas là et d'une
certaine manière en dépit de leur
enthousiasme et de leur bonne volonté
ils sont perçus par les jeunes comme des
acteurs extérieurs ça a été dit tout à
l'heure très bien sur les incendies de
bibliothèque c'est plus notre
bibliothèque
c'est
celle qu'on nous a imposé d'une C d'une
d'une certaine
façon je me suis beaucoup intéressé
enfin je me suis demandé pourquoi la
France avait des émeutes et que beaucoup
de nos pays voisins n'en avaient pas or
quand on regarde le les indicateurs
généraux d'inégalité sociale et
d'inégalité urbaine un grand nombre de
pays qui nous entourent ont des
inégalités sociales plutôt plus fortes
que les nôtres et des inégalités
urbaines qui ne sont pas tellement plus
faibles
or il y a pas vraiment d'émeut et ça
quand il aux derniers émeutes de juillet
de de cette année beaucoup de
journalistes américains anglais
allemands poser la question mais
pourquoi chez vous il y a ce phénomène
qui ne
se qui qui au fond que l'on ignore même
si évidemment on a des des violences
juvénil des bagarres de la délinquence
des trafics et cetera mais la révolte et
les meut n'existe pas alors je me suis
intéressé à à une comparaison de la
France et de l'Allemagne
alors pourquoi il y a une grande
communauté turque en Allemagne qui est
marginalisée qui est exclue qui est
victime de racisme et cetera et pourquoi
il y a pas d'émeut là et pourquoi nous
en avons chez nous alors la réponse à
cette question est est quand même un peu
troublante c'est c'est que au fond chez
nous en France euh les gens qui vivent
dans ces quartiers qui sont souvent des
gens immigrés enfant immigrés depuis
plusieurs générations mais toujours vu
comme des
immigrés sont en réalité assez fortement
assimilés à l'identité et la culture
française au fond l'héritage colonial
c'est que ils doivent devenir des
Français comme les autres ce qui est
très bien l'héritage colonial moins
sympathique c'est qu'ils héritent d'un
vieux de vieilles traditions raciste
aussi bon mais en tout cas ils sont
beaucoup plus assimilé par l'école par
les politiques publiques ce sont des
gens qui de qui qui seront des Français
comme les autres à un moment donné et en
même temps ce sont des ces groupes-là
sont beaucoup plus exclus
économiquement que les autres si on
regarde le cas de l'Allemagne et je ne
je voudrais bien me faire comprendre je
ne souhaite pas que nous devenions
allemand pour autant mais il va de soit
que les Turcs en Allemagne sont beaucoup
plus intégrés
économiquement que ne le sont les
immigrés français par un système de
formation scolaire duel qui
est très centré sur les entreprises et
cetera et en même temps que ça reste une
communauté turque très largement
auto-organisé très largement tourné vers
la Turquie que personne n'imagine qu'il
deviendront des allemands comme les
autres d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas le droit
de vote et ils ne pourront pas le
devenir et eux-mêmes ne souhaitent pas
pour la la plupart d'entre eux devenenir
allemand donc vous avez d'un côté une
société qui assimile culturellement et
qui
exclut socialement ça serait plutôt nous
et ça rend fou d'une certaine façon et
vous avez de l'autre côté une société
parce que ces traditions nationales
entre nous pas toujours sympathique font
que on n'envisage pas
d'assimiler les communautés turques
alors qu'on va tout faire pour assimiler
des Allemands qui viennent du Caucase
euh qui sont mais qui sont ethniquement
vu comme les Allemands mais qui sont
économiquement qui ont une place qui
était au fond celle qu'avaient les
travailleurs immigrés dans la France de
la société industrielle ils étaient
maltraités mais ils avaient une place
dans les grandes usines et cetera donc
je crois que nous sommes dans ce
paradoxe aujourd'hui et que la crise des
banlieux de mon point de vue est à la
fois une crise sociale mais ce que j'ai
dit est d'une grande banalité mais
fondamentalement c'est une crise
démocratique je répète quand on regarde
l'histoire des l'histoire des
démocraties c'est la capacité de
transformer des émeutes en revendication
c'est la capacité de transformer des
classes dangereuses en classes
abborieuses c'est la capacité de faire
entrer dans un système des gens qui n'y
sont pas or je crois que cette capacité
là elle est aujourd'hui extrêmement
faible ça a déjà été dit de 1000
manières mais je crois qu'elle est
faible parce que les quartiers se sont
tellement fermés sur eux-mêmes que ni
les
acteurs je dirais de l'État les
enseignants les travailleurs sociaux les
militants de ne vivent dans ces
quartiers ils y travaillent mais ils
n'en sont plus et donc ils sont perçus
comme venant du dehors que les les gens
de ces quartiers qui réussissent et qui
rentrent dans ces professions eux aussi
quittent les quartiers donc d'une
certaine manière il y a plus de vecteur
moi je me souviens avoir fait des
entretiens avec des enseignants me
disant moi je veux pas vivre là pour un
tas de raisons mais en particulier parce
que j'ai pas envie de rencontrer les
parents d'élèves sur le marché alors
que la tradition c'était que j' j'allais
bien finir par les rencontrer sur le
marché voilà donc je crois que là ce
sont des choses qui sont creusées
l'école ne tient pas ses promesses et et
donc elle est l'objet d'un ressentiment
considérable puisque au fond l'école
française ne cesse de dire aux élèves tu
n'as qu'une manière de t'en sortir c'est
l'école et comme tu n'es pas bon tu t'en
sortiras pas et on voit se développer
pas simplement de l'échec scolaire ce
qui est un problème aujourd'hui
avec les les donné PISA mais on voit se
développer du refus scolaire de du rejet
de l'école puisque d'une certaine
manière on sauve cette dignité
des choant à l'école les habitants des
quartiers qu'on a vu pendant les émeutes
le disent très nettement il disent nous
sommes l'objet de politique publique
nous ne sommes jamais les acteurs des
politiques publiques c'estàdire que ce
sont des choses extrêmement simple il
vous disent on a construit tel
équipement on n jamais demandé on nous a
jamais demandé notre avis on a mis en
place t dispositif nous n'avons jamais
eu à dire notre mot sur ce dispositif
donc d'une certaine manière euh
euh on fabrique des communautés exclu
mais la parole de ces communauté on peut
pas l'entendre parce qu'elle est
communautaire je veux dire que je vais
dire les choses de manière brutale si
vous mettez dans le même quartier des
gens pauvres qui croient à la même
religion et qui s'identifient à cette
religion pour sauver leur dignité que
vous leur disiez vous ne pouvez pas
parler au nom de cette religion parce
qu'elle brise l'univers
républicain d'abord vous fabriquez du
radicalisme et vous les rendez fou
bon les Allemands avec les turqus ont
pas ce problème puisque les Turcs
s'intéressent à la Turquie et ont des
problèmes religieux liés à la Turquie
plus plus qu'à l'Allemagne mais vous
vous comprenez bien qu'on ne pourra pas
à mon avis l'enjeu essentiel aujourd'hui
c'est de refabriquer alors c'est ça fait
très longue de bois mais un minimum de
mixité sociale dans ces quartiers ça ça
me paraît tout à fait essenel C de
trouver des voies de mobilité sociale
qui font que les gens restent dans le
quartier et ne fuit
pas dès qu'ils sont sortis de du ghetto
et je crois que c'est notre capacité
politique qui est qui est interrogé
euh à à travers ces
émeutes je je crois évidemment mais ça
c'est un autre débat que il faudra bien
un jour redéfinir les formes
d'intervention de la police dont les
polici et les jeunes sont les uns et les
autres des victimes il y a quand même
une singularité française dans la
gestion de l'ordre public qui devrait
nous interroger c'est en tout cas là
aussi ce que montrre les
comparaisons
internationales je vous remercie
merci pardon de collègues sont présents
avec moi il y a-t-il des
questions madame n alors vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président merci
à vous quatre vraiment pour pour vos vos
apports vos vos réflexions vos analyses
qui sont je crois quand même assez
largement
convergentes je je m'interroger alors je
sais pas plus directement à qui il faut
poser la question justement parce que
c'est quand même assez assez convergent
il y a il y a une
euh tout même une une petite
contradiction dans le sens où
euh il y a une question qui se pose
enfin il a par rapport à ce qu'on a ce
que vous dites là aujourd'hui et ce que
nous on a entendu dans des auditions
précédentes sur le fait que finalement
mis à part d'abord à dener et puis un
peu en île-de-fance l'élément
déclencheur de la mort de de Naël a été
finalement une une motivation assez
faible et que en réalité on est on est
très vite tomber dans euh des émeutes
qui n'avaient pas de de de de sens ou de
revendication
politique qu'on pouvait identifier et
alors vous ne dites pas non plus qu'
c'est clairement hein que c'est pas des
des revendications politiques
identifiées mais enfin vous vous avez
une analyse euh qui quand même montre
bien que même si ça n'est pas il y a pas
de revendication politique verbalisée il
y a pas d'organisation politique que il
y a quand même des sources très
politiques euh à euh à ces à ses émeutes
euh finalement euh et que et que donc on
ne peut pas simplement les résumer à une
forme de niilisme ou à euh euh à une
simple euh volonté d'en profiter pour
euh euh piller des magasins et et
revendre et donc dans une logique un peu
consumérist que même ça aussi c'est
finalement c'est un acte social euh et
et donc aussi euh euh politique et donc
je j'aimerais euh euh peut-être
avoir un peu vos vos réactions sur
peut-être cette ces premières analyses
qu'on a qu'on a eu qui ont tendance
peut-être à à être omnibulé par le
niveau de la violence qui est
effectivement assez frappant et qui qui
nous a
été décrit de manière très saisissante
par les policiers qu'on a entendu les
policiers les gendarmes qu'on a entendu
hier notamment et où on a eu un niveau
de violence beaucoup plus élevé je crois
que ce qu'on avait pu voir auparavant
euh mais euh
euh mais finalement aussi peut-être puis
qu'il y a eu de la violence dans les au
moment des gilets jaunes il y a eu de la
violence dans les manifestations dans
les outresmères qu'il avait eu
auparavant il y a eu de la violence un
peu dans les autour des des
manifestation retraite même si c'était
moindre ce qui veut dire que c'est
vience qui est pas spécifique à ces
quartiers populaires euh que c'est
peut-être plus un contexte plus général
euh et euh et et donc quel est le
peut-être
le
le l'interprétation politique qu'on doit
qu'on doit essayer de de faire beaucoup
plus fortement de ça malgré le fait
qu'il y a une forme
de enfin je qui donne l'impression comme
ça de primabord de de nilisme et de et
de simplement de consumérisme qui n'a
pas de signific enfin qui qui qui qui
peut être facilement balayé dans un peu
trop facilement parfois balayer dans
revernement merci Monsieur
Rogel oui
euh vous
avez dit le mot il faudrait
déspécialiser
euh vous monsieur vous avez parlé du du
ghetto qu'on était en train de fabriquer
en en diminuant la mixité euh je me
demande si nos politique publique ne ne
sont pas allés à l'encontre finalement
de de l'objectif puisque la politique de
la ville conduit à spécialiser de plus
en plus les quartiers
euh je le le fait
que les maires n'ai pas la main sur le
peuplement fait que on peut pas agir
dans le sens de la mixité sociale moi
j'ai des quartiers qui se sont
gettoïés j'ai bien compris aussi que les
institutions ne sont pas les
institutions qui viennent des quartiers
mais des institutions qu'on les
médiathèques qu'on jetteent dans les
quartiers et donc c'est pas les
leurs et quels sont les selon vous les
les incidences les les cons votre
constat conduit à un certain nombre de
conclusions institutionnel qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait changer dans nos
politiques publiques pour arriver à un
résultat plus acceptable parce qu'on a
mis énormément d'argent on a refait ces
quartiers moi j'ai reconstruit des
quartiers entiers dans ma ville et
finalement ça n'a absolument pas
amélioré la situation euh vous avez
beaucoup parler des médiathèques mais
aussi toutes les cantines scolaires les
cantines scolaires de leurs propres
écoles qui ont été brûlées euh donc
est-ce que vous pourriez à partir du
constat que vous avez
fait nous dire un peu ce qu'il faudrait
qu'on change pour que nos politiques
publiques soient arrivent à un résultat
plus efficace parce que à la limite les
gens disent c'est beaucoup d'argent jeté
par la fenêtre en fait
voilà bien vous avez une minute
j'exagère monsieur mercl peut-être ou
monsieur jardin puis signalez-vous hein
pour prendre la parole pas de problème
alors euh pour pour pour dire les choses
de manière très très
rapide on a on a parler des des des
constats paradoxaux des des espèces de
contradictions qu'on qu'on observe ce
qui est clair c'est que dans tout ce qui
est devant nous rien n'est univoque je
prends la question que que rien ne va
dans un sens clair et donc pour
reprendre la la question que vous vous
posiez d'une certaine façon comme l'a
dit François Dubet effectivement on peut
dire par par exemple si au lieu d'avoir
une mobilisation ou une réaction des
jeunes que c'est que que s'était-il
passé si c'était des mères des mamans on
a par exemple à Toulouse j'ai j'ai
beaucoup enquêté sur une association
dans le quartier des zizards ce sont des
mamans qui se mobilisent pour défendre
les adolescents suite aux violences
liées au narcotrafic et cetera donc qui
protège la vie des adolescents on a une
protest d'une autre nature bon qu'est-ce
qui se passe avec ces autres acteurs qui
ne prennent pas le devant de la scène
qui ne viennent pas sur le devant de la
scène pour
transformer la la la révolte en
revendication comme l'a dit François
Dubet mais de l'autre côté qu'est-ce que
nous avons eu le 27 juin l'image d'un
policier qui tue un jeune commun euh
avec son arme de service et ça c'est une
c'est un fait nouveau et donc il y a la
la on peut dire et et et nous serons
tous
d'accord la démocratie est malade mais
la maladie serait je dirais docteur
beaucoup plus grave si devant ces images
rien ne s'était passé et donc la le fait
qu'il y ait eu une révolte généralisée
montre une certaine santé de la
citoyenneté ce serait beaucoup plus
grave si nous étions dans des situations
comme par exemple connaissent le Brésil
ou le Mexique où la violence est
quotidienne la violence je dis des armes
à feu d'un côté et de l'autre et que il
y avait une indifférence généralisée
c'était intégrée à la vie démocratique
la démocratie fonctionne avec des morts
dans la rue ou dans les espaces des
quartiers populaires en France ce n'est
pas possible il y en a un et la France
s'enflamme et ça je dirais tant
mieux je n'aimerais pas j'aimerais qu'il
n'y ait pas des écoles des commiss iat
des voilà prise par cible mais il y a ce
n'est pas clair il faut y donner la
clarté et ça c'est à la parole politique
de la construire cette clarté de l'autre
côté que se passe-t-il avec les
institutions il y a une présence des
institutions et en cela je me distancie
un petit peu je comprends parfaitement
bien ce que François duedit autour du
peuplement et et c'est exact mais il y a
une présence institutionnelle cette
présence institution institutionnelle
est à la fois le salut et le problème on
le voit à travers l'école ceux qui s'en
sortent à l'école hop tant mieux mais
ils s'en vont et donc c'est c'est la
bonne intervention de la République de
la r de la démocratie sociale mais en
même temps c'est la porte qui se ferme
Moné de tout un tas de gens pour qui
l'avenir sera compromis parce qu'il
maîtrise pas la grand-mère et
l'orthographe et donc on dit à ces
gens-là tu ne sais pas bien écrire tu
n'auras pas un travail digne d'un avenir
prometteur et donc on voit bien que
cette cette institution va cristalliser
euh une une une une situation incroyable
si le logement social vous donne des
logements de qualité tout va bien et la
la République vous soutient mais si les
ascenseurs sont en panne la même
institution qui est la solution à vos
problèmes devient la source des
problèmes et la même chose se passe aux
urgences de l'hôpital au contact avec la
police et cetera les institutions de
l'État social disysfonctionn
parce que elle ell disfonctionnent en
interne dans leur fonctionnement
interne mais aussi parce qu'elles n'ont
pas la capacité à répondre aux problèmes
sociaux l'école ne peut pas moduler le
marché du travail et donc qu' que le
muscle a perdu sa valeur dans le marché
du travail en France c'est une question
qui échappe à l'action des instituteurs
donc on peut pas demander aux
institutions de ressourre tous les
problèmes ce sont des situations
paradoxal qui ne trouveront pas de
solutions faciles et évidentes sur le
plan local je veux dire qu quand les
bibliothécaires me demandent mais quoi
faire de mieux rien de mieux vous ne
pouvez pas mieux
faire malheureusement vous serez
confronté à une situation
conflictuelle la barque sera sécouée par
les vents qui traversent ces espaces
sociaux quoi que vous en fassiez ce
n'est pas un pessimisme c'est un constat
d'observateur disons euh c'est c'est
malheureux de dire ça à un élu c'est
malheureux de dire ça au directeur d'une
bibliothèque euh mais je ne pense pas
qu'il y
ait rien d'autre à faire que de
continuer à faire ce qui est
fait alors Monsieur jardin peut-être
quelques quelques points rapidement en
complément sur sur la question des
origines des émeutes et du niilisme ça a
été dit mais je crois que si il avait
pas eu les images il y aurait pas eu le
même impact et au-delà des images la
réaction politique au plus haut niveau
de l'État a finalement souligner l'enjeu
et l'importance de ce qui s'était passé
à
nanter et les déclarations par la voix
de son avocat du mise en cause ont
confirmé le caractère intentionnel du
tir pas le caractère homicide mais le
caractère intentionnel donc on nétait
pas dans une circonstance d'accident en
en cas d'espèce donc je pense que ça ça
a alimenté une conflictualité qui
n'aurait pas exister autrement mais je
pense qu'on est convaincu que si on
avait pas eu ces images il n'y aurait
pas eu des protestations de cette
ampleur sur la question des trajectoires
des quartiers je pense que les
trajectoires sont très différentes selon
les quartiers il y a des territoires
marginalisés qui sont aux portes des
grandes métropoles qui elles connaissent
des dynamiques de gentrification et
d'ambourgeoisement parce qu'elles
bénéficient en fait d'un écosystème et
d'un contexte socio-économique qui
permet le développement l'arrivée des
transport en commun l'installation
d'entreprise et c'est ce qu'on voit
notamment en scène Saint-Denis qui est
un territoire qui se différencie très
fortement et puis on a des quartiers
marginalisés de métropole plus petites
dans des régions plus éloignées des
grands poles urbains où là la
marginalité est durable en l'absence
véritablement de perspective de
développement structurel de ces
territoires donc je pense qu'un des
enjeux essentiels c'est d'agir peut-être
sur ces territoires qui n'ont pas
d'autres ressources que l'action
publique pour bénéficier d'un
développement social et économique alors
que des territoires ont pu capter des
dynamiques lié lié à l'activité
économique générale je pense qu' un
point qui passe un peu sous silence
c'est la question de la démographie de
ces quartiers qui deviennent des
quartiers de plus en plus vieillissants
qui vont rester des quartiers plus
jeunes que le reste de la France mais
dans lesquels les enjeux du
vieillissement et la transformation de
la structure des familles et des
générations sont sont très importants
euh et c'est quelque chose qui va sans
doute modifier leur rapport aux
politiques et leur rapport aux
institutions dans les années qui
viennent et peut-être un dernier point
sur quelque chose qui est souvent un peu
un impensé ou quelque chose qui est
pensé à part c'est le fait que il y a
des entrepreneurs moraux et identitaires
qui cherchent à formuler euh un un
discours politique dans ces quartiers et
ça passe parfois par les structures qui
sont liées au courant islamiste ou
rigoriste qui tirent les bénéfices bah
de cette conflictualité avec les
institutions et qui tente de dire nous
nous avons la capacité à générer les
institutions locales et petit travail
que nous avons fait avec mon collègue
Hugo Micheron sur les contenus en ligne
des organisations salafiste en France
elle parle beaucoup des émeutes elle les
condamne systè matiquement elles en
parlent en termes sociaux et elles
s'intéressent aux conditions de vie dans
les quartiers donc il y a des dynamiques
qui sont vraiment des logiques
d'implantation idéologique et politique
qui s'inscrivent dans des espaces
interstitiels et dans des vides pour ces
population parce que ben elles ne sont
plus immigrées elles ne sont plus
forcément ouvrières ou pas dans le monde
du
travail le quartier n'est pas quelque
chose qui produit tes propres ressources
d'identification le rapport à
l'ethnicité et pas un rapport légitime
en France pour se construire une
identité politique ben leur religion est
un support disponible pour construire
une identité politique et ça se produit
dans un certain nombre de territoirees
pour une certaine partie de la
population merci Monsieur jardin
peut-être du côté de Monsieur Domingo
monsieur
dub allez-y allez-y monsieur doming je
relance mon micro
bonjour beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites moi je pense ce que sous
monsieur dub sur les contradictions
finalement de l'action publique ça me
paraît au cœur de d'un certain nombre de
de nosulté euh c'està-dire des
injonctions contradictoires et une
parole politique qui pèse hein on a dans
son écosystème médiatique qui est qui
est lui-même conflictuel où on parle des
quartiers ou des populations des
quartiers sans qu'en effet que que les
les premiers concernés soient soi
relayés donc on a vu aussi pendant ces
émeutes les habitants qui se sont
mobilisés pour sauver leurs écoles donc
euh vous parliez tout à l'heure he mes
collègues parlent de
l'expérience de maman qui essaient de
construire des choses donc je pense qu'
il y a des enjeux où il faut
reconstruire du politique par le basin
retisser du lien social et pas seulement
penser dans un sur le plan purement
urbanistique ou dur euh il faut retisser
des formes de lien social les réinventer
peut-être parce qu'elles se sont
peut-être déstructuré au fil des ans
donc là il y a il y a un enjeu par le
bas qui implique d'ailleurs très
directement à mon avis les collectivités
locales leur capacité avec l'État à à
avoir
une une logique qui aille dans le même
sens et sans contradiction et puis il y
a peut-être aussi un volet plus plus
sociétal plus méta hein sur la parole
publique sur la manière dont on parle de
ces quartiers dont on identifie les
populations dont on en parle parce que
je pense qu'elles sont aussi réceptive
à à à cette forme de décrochage hein euh
qui fait qu'ensuite ça a été aussi dit
il y a des formes alternatives au-delà
de l' meutes qui vont permettre de de
construire du politique du politique S N
plus ordinaire mais beaucoup plus
concret et qui permet de de vivre au
jour le jour et donc le le religieux est
un de ses leviers mais aussi la
marginalisation hein parfois est une de
ses conséquences euh c'est-à-dire on ne
parle plus il y a pas d'émeut et là
aussi c'est problématique hein parce que
ça veut dire qu'il y a sûrement des gens
qui s'enfment qui s'enferment dans dans
dans des processus de très grande
pauvreté et avec une incapacité à se
mobiliser même même par le BIS de la
violence
donc je pense qu'on a un effet un
problème de modèle et qui qui est en
tension parce qu'en plus on est sur la
une province républicaine celle de
l'école mais plus largement une province
républicaine qui est très forte en
France et dont les populations et
notamment les populations jeunes voient
bien que cette promesse a des
difficultés à se mettre concrètement en
œuvre et donc là on est dans une vraie
tension c'est une tenstion où l'État
finalement fait beaucoup de choses en
France mais cette action elle est mal
perçue et il y a une forme de
désajustement très fort entre ce que
font les autorités publiques et et la
manière dont dont cette action est est
perçue est appropriée dans dans ces
quartiers donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
a et c'est c'est là où on rejoue l'enjeu
démocratique c'est comment on on sort
d'une de dispositif pour recréer des
formes de démocratie plus ordinaires
dans le cadre de C de cette politique de
la ville alors peut-être avec moins
parfois d'argent mais avec des une
reconstruction dansun lien social qui
aujourd'hui est à la peine et qui est
lié à tous les processus qui on qui ont
pu être exposés
précédemment merci Monsieur Domingo je
sais pas si Monsieur Dubet veut prendre
la parole non je très très rapidement je
je je pardonnez-moi oui très très
rapidement je voudrais rappeler que il
faut il faut admettre à la fois que ce
sont des révoltes et que ce sont des
émeutes et que dans lesmeutes on en
connaît depuis très longtemps dans les
émeutes il y a il y a il y a il y a des
rationalités qui
sont strictement délinquantes ludiqu le
bonheur de détruire et ça ne date pas
d'hier je veux dire on a toute une
histoire des émeutes qui montre que
c'était pas très sympathique mais il
n'empêche que le cœur c'est celui d'une
injustice d'une révolte et cetera donc
euh je crois que c'est on est on est
confronté à ça et et peut-être au-delà
aujourd'hui de des banlieux après tout
j'été très frappé de voir comment le
mouvement des gilets jaunes a été a eu
de grandes difficultés à produire une
revendication c'est des gens très en
colère mais euh qui avait beaucoup de
mal à produire une une demande une
demande donc c'est c'est un mécanisme
assez général ce qui nous pourrait créer
d'ailleurs chez beaucoup d'entre nous la
nostalgie des syndicats des mouvements
d'éducation populaire de toutes ces
machines à refroidir les colères que
nous avons peut-être trop mal traité bon
je voudrais le dire au passage moi je je
crois que le remplacement des mouvements
d'éducation pour populaire par des
prestataires de service c'est pas une
c'est pas forcément une bonne chose
c'est même pas une bonne chose du tout
donc je je je crois que on est quand
même devant ce
problème alors il n'est pas que français
mais nous sommes particulièrement forts
là-dessus parce que nous sommes
centralisateurs et cetera et cetera donc
je crois qu'il faut bien comprendre
là-dessus
euh la deuxième chose ça a été dit et
nous sommes tous embarrassés là-dessus
c'est que si on veut que les acteurs de
ces quartiers deviennent euh les
habitants de ces quartiers deviennent
des acteurs il faudra bien admettre au
jour qu'il deviennent des acteurs des
acteurs en étant ce qu'ils sont or il et
c'est notre tout notre problème avec
l'islam après tout euh c'est à la fois
c'est à la fois des choses extrêmement
dangereuses et c'est à la fois la seule
chose qui fait qui fabrique du lien de
la dignité euh et donc je je je je suis
moi comme tout tout Français normalement
constitué très embarrassé mais mais on
peut pas dire au 19e siècle au breton
soyez sympa organisez-vous mais sans
catholicisme bon les bretan était
catholique voilà et donc il y a quelque
chose de de cet ordre là qui qui n'est
pas réglé et de ce point de vue- là le
discours médiatique de stigmatisation
est tout à fait terrifiant et je
voudrais bien préciser que je n'ai
aucune naïveté par
rapport à certaine forme
d'islamisme ensuite je crois qu'on peut
agir quand même sur le peuplement on a
peut-être un peu renoncé rapidement à
essayer CR de créer un peu de mixité
dans les quartiers et je voudrais dire
c'est le dernier point que on pourrait
agir beaucoup mieux qu'on ne le fait sur
la mixité scolaire je veux dire que on
puisqu'on a un Toulousain parmi nous il
y a eu un exemple célèbre à Toulouse où
on a tout cassé un collège ultra
guettoisé ça a pris beaucoup de temps
pour convaincre les collèges de classe
moyenne d'à côté avoir quelques Arabes
chez eux ça serait pas une catastrophe
mais ça a marché donc on peut le faire
et je crois que de ce côté-là aussi si
on faisait confiance aux acteurs locaux
on s'en tierait parfois un peu mieux que
nous nous le faisons après tout les pays
plus décentralisé que le nôutre sentir
pas plus mal sur tout ces
questionsl merci Monsieur mais vraiment
c'est passionnant tout ce que vous nous
avez dit alors moi je partage beaucoup
de choses et je pense qu'il y a pas une
solution facile mais la question du
peuplement je pense que c'est une
question fondamentale et elle répond
parfaitement à ce que vous disez tout à
l'heure c'estàdire que la gettoisation
elle tient aussi beaucoup au au
mécanisme même qu'on a mis en place aux
règles qu'on s'est infligé pour de tas
de raisons positiv ou pas positive mais
qui ont fait que les maires enfin les
élus locaux pour faire plus simple se
sont retrouvés bloqués dans des
situations qui auraient sans doute géré
différemment alors sans excès on est
bien d'accord différemment et mais en
tous les cas de manière plus équilibrée
je pas raconter ma vie d'élu j'ai été m
pendant 20 ans d'une commune du
rô avec des quartiers c un petit
territoire mais dense 27000 habitants
avec des des
quartiers compliqués on a réussi à gérer
tout ça correctement mais avec avec
cette forme d'équilibre qu'on a
réintroduit dans certains secteurs dans
d'autres on n'a pas hésité à démolir ça
va être en cours de reconstruction je
vous cache pas que le mon inquiétude sur
la reconstruction est grande parce qu'on
est encore sur les mécanismes anciens en
terme de réflexion et que si on n prend
pas garde ce que l'on va faire ou ce qui
pourrait être fait dans les années qui
viennent va générer dans quelques années
la même situation que nous avons
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est toujours sur
ce même modèle et il faut arriver je
pense un en sortir et puis je termine
par le un petit moment de gloire de ma
vie communale j'avais dans un quartier
une école primaire qui était dans une
situation de gettoisation mais totale
absolument totale et j'avais obligé je
le dis vraiment obligé après une grosse
colère d'ailleurs l'éducation nationale
de dire on rase l'école et on réaffecte
les enfants en dehors deécole maternel
dans les autres quartiers de dans les
autres écoles des autres quartiers de la
ville avec un système qu'on av appelé
buzing parce que le bus les prenait
enfins et ça continue toujours
d'ailleurs parce que le quartier n'est
pas encore reconstruit et bien je ne
regrette pas du tout une seule seconde
de l'avoir fait parce que finalement
tous les directeurs des autres écoles y
compris les enfants tout ça s'est passé
merveilleusement bien avec des résultats
scolaires de grande
et on a probablement aidé des gamins à à
faire des choses qu'il n'auraient pas
fait si on avait pas fait ça et alors
c'est un peu particulier parce que mon
territoire est pas très grand on peut le
faire mais le principe en tous les cas
est pour moi un principe qui mérite
d'être multiplié lorsque les situations
deviennent inextricable sinon sorti
rapport bon tout ça c'est une petite
réflexion avant le déjeuner parce que je
vous ai écouté et que ça m'a rappelé
quelques souvenirs mais la complexité
que vous avez évoqué est quand même tout
à fait fondamentale et si on se pose pas
les bonnes questions je suis pas sûr
qu'on trouve les bonnes solution mais
bon en toutous les cas merci et merci de
nous avoir nourri l'esprit aujourd'hui
et probablement peut-être d'autres
contacts possibles avec la commission
puisque notre travail le rapport sera
rendu qu'au mois de février peut-être
mars mais plutôt février c'est
l'objectif et si on a besoin de revenir
vers vous on le fera bien volontiers si
vous nous le permettez bien
sûr merci à vous merci aux collègues et
puis susp suspendre la Réunion et vous
souhaitez tout de même bon appétit je
crois qu'il est l'heure merci merci
merci